tunisia's president moves to dissolve a
top judicial watchdog kai syed assumed
executive powers last year and now
accuses the body of corruption but is
this a slide backwards in the only
democracy to emerge from the arab spring
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
elizabeth piranham in doha tunisia's
president has declared times up for the
body responsible for appointing judges
and keeping an eye on them kai said says
the supreme judicial council is biased
broken and a thing of the past
specifically syed accuses it of delaying
politically sensitive investigations
into the killings of left-wing activists
in 2013.
demonstrations were held on sunday
commemorating their deaths
we will work to put an end to this
miserable situation and we will work to
put in place a temporary law or decree
for the supreme judicial council this
council should consider itself from the
past starting this moment
the democratic transition in tunisia
since the 2011 revolution has been
tumultuous and matters came to a head
last year in july president syed sacked
the prime minister and froze parliament
his opponents accused him of staging a
coup but scythe has argued he acted
legally to rescue the country
during protests against him and also
rallies of support side announced in
september that he'd rule by decree this
allowed him to appoint cabinet members
set policy and put aside parts of the
constitution last month he initiated an
online consultation to draft a new
constitution but he hasn't involved any
major political or civil society groups
in the process
well let's bring in our guests in tunis
is said onisi a member of the disbanded
tunisian parliament in syracuse mohammed
biahamami is political scientist and
researcher at syracuse university's
maxwell school and fadol ali reza is
editor-in-chief of
that's a tunisian news and analysis
website a very warm welcome to all of
you and miss unicia i'll start with you
in tunis we'll mention some of the moves
that president said has taken over the
past six months the tunisian parliament
that you were a part of has been
disbanded is the birthplace of the arab
spring on its way to becoming an
autocracy
yes uh exactly so today mark actually uh
you know the beginning of the seventh
month after the freezing of the
parliament by the president
paisai who is um
you know continuing on this
pathway to installing a real
dictatorship in tunisia and to dismantle
the tunisian states with the allens this
morning
or let's say very late uh
yesterday evening
uh in the hashkey of the ministry of
interior of the dissolution of the
higher
court of justice or the higher council
of
judges which is another step towards um
personal power confiscation of power and
the destruction of every single voice
who would be against isis let's put that
uh latest move to mr alireza who's also
in tunis is president said
what do you make of what he's done is he
right in his criticism because his
criticism is very strong of the supreme
judicial council i mean he says that the
members have been taking what he calls
billions and bribes and have been
delaying important
cases on corruption on terrorism
well there's certainly legitimate
criticisms of the judiciary i think that
can be made
we've certainly seen cases where um even
there was a judge that was stopped by
police and had
a million
over a million deniers in the car so
certainly cases like this have fed into
what has a widely perceived uh
understanding that the judiciary
has had issues there's been attempts to
have an independence of the judiciary um
particularly since the setting of the
higher judicial council in 2016 but ever
since the 2011 revolution there have
been attempts to try and build an
independent judiciary um what the
president is saying and accusing and
what he seems to be building his project
on uh is saying that the judiciary has
uh not been doing its job but it is a
party to partisan uh interest uh at the
same time we do seem that actually he's
giving more executive control over the
judiciary uh and as a result of that
we're seeing actually judges pushing
back certainly the higher judicial
council itself has been in the
crosshairs of the president since
september uh so it's been several months
that we've seen increasing pressure by
the executive branch on the judiciary
and certainly judges and judges unions
have also been very upset at this and
pushing back saying that while there are
a legitimate criticisms perhaps on the
slowness of cases uh that they would not
like to see the executive and the
presidency itself have greater control
over the judiciary itself mr hamami how
do you
address something like a judiciary that
isn't moving fast enough on some of the
most you know important cases judges
finding um you know being found with um
with a lot of money i mean what
president scythe has done is it
warranted or is it an overreach and
that's part of
the sort of wider moves that he's been
making for the past six months
well the jojo was arrested with cash in
her car was arrested and she's being
prosecuted you don't need to dissolve
the entire institution to hold
a few bad apples um
accountable uh the problem with side is
that he does not distinguish between
misbehavior of individuals judges that
happen in every single institution
including the ministry of interior
upon which he rely to um to uh oppress
his his opponents um
[Music]
but the problem with him is that he's
attacking the actual institution that
was built
after the revolution that judges have
been fighting for
uh for for the four years even under ben
ali they were talking for calling for
the uh for the implementation for the
creations of such an institution so the
main problem with the side is not is
that instead of trying to
solve institutional problems he's simply
dissolving his
solving these institutions and attacking
his opponents
um in fact uh that when we say that the
the
people do not trust the system the
producers isn't actually
not true uh we have data from multiple
surveys uh the most recent one was one
in november uh by the center for
the by site it's american institution uh
national private enterprise with the
tunisian company and it told that 60
percent of tunisians do trust the court
system um so as i said the problem is
with with a few apple but apples and
side is using um that uh pretext to
attack the entire institution and has
that uh ms anisi i'll bring you in here
now has that um if he's attacking
institutions rather than what mr hamami
describes as a few bad apples within the
institutions is that costing him support
because
you know he was elected with wide
support from across the political
parties um your party itself another
supported him and the
what he did you know when he dissolved
parliament i mean that was also had some
very popular support
is he now losing that support
apparently he is
because he
basically um eliminated everyone around
him what is dangerous with faisal is
that his very obscure project that we
don't really know about it because he
never took the time to explain it to
people he refused uh dialogue he refused
pluralism he refused diversity he
refused confrontation of opinion so in
that way he's really not you know
someone who's in front of uh democracy
but he's more and more uh isolated i
think that uh the support he uh
had in in uh last summer in the uh you
know
middle of uh one of the
hardest moments of the the pandemic and
the way he also by the way used uh this
pandemic for himself yesterday to
justify the authorization of
demonstrations in his favor today he
basically said that the um pandemi and
the pandemic sorry and the sanitary
situation evolved in the good way so
people could actually take on the
streets and demonstrate in his favor
what we are seeing uh since this morning
is that there is only probably two or
three dozens of people who actually went
uh outside and took the street to
support in favor of his decisions of
yesterday evening in the same time he is
a person who at
two
occasions
gave strict orders to uh basically uh uh
uh forbidden demonstrations absolutely
we saw we saw deadly results we saw
deadly results i believe on january 14th
then an anti-syed protester was actually
killed many people were arrested and
that's because there was a ban on
demonstrations and yet on sunday people
are being allowed to demonstrate in
support or rather in support of what
he's been saying and against the supreme
judicial council mr alireza how
problematic is that especially from a
human rights perspective at this point
certainly it's extremely problematic
that only the protests that are approved
or accepted by the president seem to
have his support i mean it seems that
the directions of his government uh
saying that there was a ban on
demonstrations there's an exception to
that for today um you know he had said
actually that he would like to dissolve
the the higher judicial council um but
he hasn't put forward something in
writing that we've seen yet um but uh at
the same time he had also said that he
called for people to go to the streets
and to protest against the higher
judicial council today um and uh as the
previous guest said there were very few
that showed up today um uh less than 200
people uh so in in that sense it does
seem to be that um in fact the the there
isn't widespread support for for for
what he's calling for um and in fact um
uh it it it does indicate that um while
previous protests have actually had
um police stopping people from coming to
gather in downtown tunis we've seen um
uh uh
various uh parties who have wanted to
demonstrate not just those opposing the
president but uh
i
uh generally wanted to sort of gather on
january 14 and just to commemorate uh
the day were also prevented from uh
meeting downtown tunis so there's a
clear discrepancy
in uh who has to assembly freedom of
assembly uh these days in
the last few months sure um mr nisi it
seems like uh president syed is on a
path right now and while he is losing
support or seems to be losing some
support at least in tunisia what about
um support from the international
community who weren't very uh
forthcoming in the condemnation you know
of dissolving parliament or many of the
other steps that were taken they seem to
want to you know give him a chance to
see what would happen where do you think
things stand now because we know that
tunisia is in the economy is in a very
bad state it needs international
money to prop up the economy and you
know multi-billion dollar
package from the international monetary
fund is on hold at the moment so how
much leverage would you say the
international community has right now
via agencies like the imf
so
what is clear today is that after six
months of uh you know grabbing power and
confiscating power uh economy is a
non-question it's a non-subject for high
side he never talked about it the only
moves he had were quite caricatural he
went
market and asked you know like directly
vendors to basically uh you know
decrease prices so people could
buy you know goods but the reality today
is that because of uh you know the
absence of rule of law because of the
absence of institutions in tunisia
investors both international but also
the you know like very local national
investors left the country people are
not willing to do anything you know
which could create employment or which
could uh you know led to uh in economic
development especially after being hit
that hard by the pandemic in tunisia was
one of the country who definitely at the
economic level struggled the most
because we are a country of uh you know
providing services so this is today
having clear impact very concrete
impacts on the streets of the market
yeah i'll just um okay please continue
yeah i just wanted to say that
we are really at the peak of a very
important social
crisis which could lead evan to violence
on the streets and this is one of the
main
fear we have today that is exactly what
i was going to put to mr hamami you know
could the sharp decline that in people's
living standards we're already hearing
of prices for many things going up you
know the price of rice and sugar going
up could a decline in people's living
standards um because of you know the
political the economic situation in the
country lead to a wider unrest in
tunisia
well to be to be precise that the the
living centers of fission have been
declining um
for
at least the last 15 years i would say
continuously um people
usually tend right now tend to associate
it with the
uh the bad parts that were adopted after
the revolution yes that was a part of
the problem um so i don't think they
associate it directly with
um
the power grab for example however uh it
is right now framed um in in the public
discourse as
as a result of sides
rejection of any willingness to
collaborate with with uh with the unions
or with the uh with the
representative of business owners
um
so
i i am skeptical of claims
that
rise this kind of fear that we will
become violent like it happened once
right in tunisia's history
in 1984
it happened
uh
that was the only i would say
really violent uh uh protest and there
was a military was deployed i don't
expect that kind of scenario to happen
again
um i um don't think that the
security apparatus would be willing to
repeat scenarios similar to 1984
um however
that made impact directly the level of
support to president kai's side
we're already seeing it declining
significantly and and yet you know we
have people like um the spokesperson of
the u.n human rights office and groups
like amnesty international they are
quite worried about the actions of the
security
apparatus mr alireza you know the u.n
human rights office saying they really
condemn the imprisonment of a senior
leader at another saying that the
incident echoes practice is not seen
since the era of president
zinali abedin ben ali and that it raises
serious questions regarding abduction
and false disappearance and arbitrary
detention
is there a role do you think for the u.n
in tunisia at the moment
the international community has been
quite vocal um and in the last few
months
they've made several statements for some
groups they would say that the
statements have not gone far enough for
other groups they would say that these
statements are actually counter
productive in terms of what they would
like to see in terms of human rights in
tunisia
on the question of
sort of
police violence there's certainly been
police violence um on economic issues
specifically um over the last several
years i mean we saw in 2018 um as mr
hamami said we haven't we haven't seen
uh
anything on the scale as as deadly as
what happened in 1984 but there
certainly has been police repression of
socio-economic protests social economic
movements across the country
particularly outside of tunis in certain
hot spots where people have have been
calling basically for uh development for
investment um actually one of the
reasons why um president uh uh kaisai
received some popularity or some support
was his promises to fight corruption but
so far what we've seen is all of the
steps that he's taken extra judicially
has been actually uh against um
political opponents but not necessarily
against uh corrupt officials or
businessmen or some of the people that
he had previously said yeah you know he
might actually uh sort of look to in
trying to solve from the corruption
issues
can he rule on his own you know mr
hamami was talking about how he's not
going to work with unions he's not
working with political parties um miss
unisa it's is it possible for him to
actually rule the country on his own he
needs some allies doesn't he especially
with the challenges facing tunisia right
now
theoretically this country cannot be led
or managed and especially after the
revolution only in
you know a context of dialogue of uh
having you know the most possible
stakeholders around one table but high
side is definitely i say it again
isolated more than uh more than ever and
uh i don't see how this could be
sustainable i i think that
what he did yesterday and the
dissolution of
this important institution is uh going
to
basically do the work it is
the grand work for
mass arresting uh you know among
political opponents this is
a step forward for the complete absence
of rule of law i don't see how political
parties
national organization can still
not call this a coup or can still
support him or evan can still you know
expect that
he will do um you know something to
basically uh take the country out of
this economic and social crisis and the
numbers are not uh are not lying i mean
uh i think we we have never been in that
position of weakness toward the
international community towards
international
financial uh institutions and that is
very well yeah let me put that to um mr
hamami because he's in the us
how much leverage does the u.s
government have you know that they
themselves a 500 million dollar
infrastructure grant is stalled the
state department is holding back some
military support funds um congress is
threatening to reduce or cancel u.s
economic assistance to tunisia unless
conditions improve
yes well there were discussions on the
leverage that the u.s has uh since the
the coup happened actually since july
um but uh it seems that the
administration is not interested in
anything like that there is some
pressure coming from the congress um
they conditioned the
the military aid specifically
uh the result of a a kind of
investigation or report that would have
to be submitted to the congress to to
evaluate the extent to which
uh the military was involved in the july
25th events
and if the military is involved then
according to u.s legislation
um the u.s cannot provide
any form of military support
and this would be the equivalent of
around a hundred million dollars
um there was no cuts actually in the
budgeting they were they did not reduce
the the budget they kept the same level
as
uh
2020 and 2019. all right
but to sum it up there is i would say a
division but the vital administration is
uh willing to work with with any form of
regime whether it's autocratic or
democratic all right we don't have very
long left in the program and i'd like to
ask a quick question to all of you
before we end uh mr alireza you know
what do you think it's going to take for
tunisia to
to return to a functioning democracy and
what would you say is at stake for the
region
well i think uh tunisian democracy is a
project that's been ongoing uh it's
certainly something that's been open to
contestation
the avenues of contestation over what a
democracy looks like and what it means
uh have changed since july 25th where
the debate is happening where this sort
of discussion is happening it's no
longer happening in parliament so some
of those discussions have gone behind
closed doors um however some of them may
be going out into the streets as well so
we'll see whether um the debate over
where tunisia is going uh whether it'll
be played out in the streets whether it
will play it out with other uh
institutions uh certainly uh unions and
different um associations have uh taken
a clear stance uh since july 25th some
of them are taking uh clearer stands uh
uh
increasingly clearer stands uh whether
they'll be uh uh uh groupings or
alliances certainly uh some of the
opponents of high side have not worked
together up till this point but they may
end up working together later on so
there's there's clearly a question mark
over which those which groups will be
there and uh mr nisi i could see you
disagreeing with that
yeah well i think it is really amazing
um to say that there is still
discussions going on in the country uh
you know uh about what the democracy
should look like when you basically have
no
uh you know uh uh
debates and public debates anymore and
not only because the parliament is shut
down but also because the media is uh
basically
not free anymore because people are
auto censoring themselves because
there is a new decree which basically
avoids
freedom for civil society organizations
and everybody is afraid everybody has a
kind of epidemic
on their head and uh you know there is
no discussions anymore we are living in
a in a situation and a context where
fear is everywhere and where people and
especially more uh you know from today
are uh uh expecting themselves to be
victims of the arbitrary because we are
living in a state of confidence
it's really important that people start
to acknowledge what is really going on
and stop you know this kind of like
double uh situation only because for
them what is important is that another
is not on a political landscape anymore
or not part of the government anymore
and should really look at the global
picture because today they are probably
you know eyesight and his uh supporters
are coming
for people that you yourself disagree
with but at some point they will come to
you because there are people who
you know very strongly right
okay i'm afraid we have run out of time
but i want to thank all of our guests
for this discussion that is said nisi in
tunis muhammad hamami in syracuse and
father ali reza also in tunis and thank
you two for watching you can see the
program again any time by visiting our
website aljazeera.com and for further
discussion do go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story for me elizabeth
piranham and the whole team here in doha
bye for now